你们是不是以为我消失了？
以为咱这个课烂尾了是吧？
怎么可能呢？对不对？
最近工作忙。
在上班啊。
今天上午有点时间，所以抓紧时间录一课，对吧？利用这一个上午的时间不会烂尾的啊，同学们放心吧。
咱的课呀。
其实你们只要愿意学。
我这么往下讲。
我感觉讲一年也有的讲。
因为什么呢？因为这个学问啊，它是很综合的一个学问。
他涉及到的东西很多，可以探讨的范围很大。
所以其实。
我们这堂课你得有个过日子的心。
你们就当是我陪伴你们。
带着你们去学。
细水长流。
当然了，你们随时可以写。
不耽误继续学，并不是说非得。比如说我们这课准备上30年，30年以以后你才出师才能下笔。不是这样的，我也在学习，我跟大家一起成长，一起探索，我们一起进步，好不好？
然后周末上个周末嗯搞了一次直播，应广大同学的强烈要求啊，必须说是应同学们的强烈要求，显得这老师对吧？矜持嘛？应同学们的强烈要求，我搞了一次直播。
然后在直播中。
有个同学提了一个很简单很愚蠢的问题，我今天拿到这儿回答一下，这个同学问啥呢？说老师。
我们听你的课。
挺开心的，我们现在也很爱你。
但是呢心里总有个顾虑。
我们到底能当成编剧吗？
我们到底能学会写剧本吗？
是吧他就产生了这个顾虑。他说你看我们毕竟是普通人呀。
很普通。
出生在普通的城市，上着普通的学校做一份普通的工作。
编剧好像很遥远。
我们能成为编剧吗？
就问我这么一个，我说是愚蠢的问题。
我问他。
我说为什么不能呢？
为什么不能呢？
在这里我跟同学们说一下，说一下我对。
学习我对做事情。
的一个一直以来我的一个。
理解。
我认为。
最起码在中国来说，世界其他地方咱不知道，最起码在中国的这个环境来说。
你想要学成一件事情，你想要学会一样东西，想要做成一件事情。
都是可以的。
没有什么不可能的。
凭什么不可以？
凭什么不可能？
壁垒一定有，但没有你想象的那么高。
我曾经有一个比喻来说做事情。
我说做任何事情，学会任何东西。
都像减肥。
你说减肥难吗？
难。
很多人减不了。
那你说减肥真的难吗？
不难。
诀窍很简单，所有人都知道减肥的秘诀都在心里清清楚楚门儿清。
管住嘴迈开腿，你只要动起来就能减肥。所有人都知道这个规律。
所以他又不难。
做事情也是这样。
你只要愿意坚持。
找到对的方法，然后坚持一定能做到。
干扰你的。
是什么呢？
啥玩意干扰你的。
比如说减肥这件事情。
什么干扰你了？
你没毅力。
对吧你不愿意坚持。
然后呢。
你老想走捷径。
泰国又出了一个什么药，对吧？哎，我听说他们有一种什么方法？
看起来不怎么动，只要坚持5分钟，相当于慢跑半小时，你在那做梦呢。
你在那做梦呢，同学们呢？
不用付出，相当于别人跑步半小时。你做梦呢？
你就是因为老想走捷径，或者是给自己没毅力找借口。然后还有呢就是怪老天。
你看那个谁谁谁。
怎么吃也不胖，人家天生瘦，人家全家都瘦，我能跟人家比吗？
对吧。
人家瘦跟你有什么关系？
人家天生就瘦，怎么吃都不胖，身材好，这叫什么？
这叫天赋。
总有人有天赋，就像学编剧一样，总有人有天赋，你明白吗？但是不耽误你减肥一样。
他跟你减肥有什么关系啊？
而且你如果是剪下来的，你原本是个胖子，你减下来的。
你搞不好你的肉比他紧实。
你比他有力量。
你比他匀称，懂这个意思吗？所以不要去想那些事情，学编剧也好，做任何事情也好。
就像减肥。
就想减肥。
方法就摆在那儿。
对吧方法就摆在那儿，只要你坚持学。
一定能做到。
没有说不可能这件事情，你不要说哎呀，我不可能做成编剧，我不可能减肥成功。你不要说不可能。
方法很简单，好吧。
那同学又要问了，那老师，你在这个我们这个减肥中扮演什么呢？
我其实就扮演你们的教练。
我督促你们。
我给你们正确的方法，给你们指正确的方向，然后督促你们训练练习。
但是主动权。
肯定在你自己手里。
所以你问我你能不能减肥成功，你能不能当成编剧？
不知道。
但是你问我可不可能？我告诉你，你百分之百可能。
就看你。
好吧。
这就是回答一下这个同学的这个疑问。
也打消一下其他同学的这个顾虑，不要总觉得。
有很多同学就你一不想努力了就找理由。
对吧嗯，看看捷径有没有可得可走，没有捷径可走，就开始找理由怨天尤人。哎呀，我出生在小县城，我又没有接触文艺的环境，对吧？那我们家都没有人能帮我帮上我，我这个钱我没有这。
我什么天赋又开始聊天赋。
没有这个问题，不要考虑这么多，好吧。
你就想象一下，你以后做任何事情，你就想象一下我说的它就像减肥。
你只要愿意坚持，啊，就能做到。
别找理由。
然后我最近确实工作比较忙，在忙什么呢？
有些同学说说老师，你不是说。
最近这个。
行情有点差，影视这个行情。
确实有点差，但是也不耽误工作忙呀，有很多事情可以做。现在我们在策划一些网剧，对吧？然后还有这个嗯。
剧场马上要开了，剧场马上也要开了，还要嗯筹划剧场里面的事情。
所以其实啊作为我们编剧来说呀，你说大环境。
好与不好。
对我们的影响没有大家想象的那么大。
因为编剧啊。
毕竟是手艺人，手艺人是靠自己吃饭的。
靠自己吃饭的对吧？你你平地抠饼对面拿贼嘛，你靠自己吃饭，你老说大环境好不好干什么？就是我给大家说什么啊，就大家一定要对编剧有个正确的理解。
就编剧。
没有你们想象的那么玄妙。
就是啊他们都是什么一帮多文艺多牛逼的人，没有那么玄妙，就是手艺人。
手艺人吃自己的手艺饭。
就是靠自己。
劳动。
去吃饭。
我年轻的时候，我给大家再多插几句，关于编剧啊，我年轻的时候。
有一个老前辈。
是个是个领导。
他曾经在私底下跟我。
聊天的时候。
点拨了我几句。
我那时候刚进社会嘛。
他就说那个。
小曹啊。
这个。
世界上的职业分三种。
分三种，我说哪三种？他说一种是强盗。
一种是骗子。
一种是鸡。
我说和解吗？
然后他说强盗。
就是。
靠强权。
好。
优势巨大的优势势能。
来赚钱，你无法抗拒。
他赚钱就是那么简单收割。
然后骗子呢。
是靠。
附加值或者是售卖别人的。
劳动。
来赚钱。
等于是。
搞搞一搞包装，搞一搞交易，搞一搞穿户去赚钱。
然后他的基就是大多数大多数人。
就是售卖自己身体的一部分赚钱做鸡嘛。
售卖自己的体力，脑力，售卖自己的劳动，售卖自己的时间去赚钱。
他当时给我讲这三个分类。
他其实是在。
鼓励我，他说年轻人啊一定是。
不能满足于座机，虽然会从座机开始，但要往上走。
做成骗子，最后做成强盗。
这是他的理解。
因为他是个强盗嘛。
他认为比强盗比骗子和鸡高级。
但其实我在这些年的工作当中。
我反而觉得做鸡最踏实。
因为你出卖自己的劳动，自己的体力。
自己的智慧去赚钱。
最心安理得也最稳定。
我们说你如果真的做一个强盗，拥有强大的不可抗力去收割。
那等你倒下的时候，你也是不可抗拒的。
而且赚那种钱，你真的会快乐吗？可能我们没有到内步也体会不到。所以我当时把这个领导的话，他虽然是鼓励我往上走，但我理解成了。
我们就好好做一只鸡嘛。
做鸡不代表就是一定是做苦力，一定放弃啊，你可以做一只名鸡嘛。
对不对？你可以做一个之强有力的鸡嘛？
就像你做编剧。
你可不可以把你的剧本越写越好？
你的能力提升上去了，对吧？然后你出卖自己的脑力、体力和时间的时候，可以卖个更好的价钱，得到更好的认可。
主动权永远在自己手里，踏踏实实的赚钱多好。
对吧？而不是说我啊一看当编剧，我如果出名了，我就千万不能以后再不能做鸡了，我得有理想，我得做骗子了，开始对吧？开始雇写手，拿你的名字。
灌在这个作品上，但其实是别人写的，是小孩写的，年轻人写的，然后呢开始批量生产，同时接20个剧本，40个小孩在这写两人一组。
你这就是开始做骗子了。
明白吗？就变了。所以我们编剧或者是我们大部分人。
做好。
一只鸡做好手艺人其实挺好的。
其实挺好的。
唐伯虎有一首诗。
叫颜值。
说的就是手艺人的生活。
后两句是啥呢？
后两句叫。
闲来写就青山脉。
不使人间造孽钱。
不使人间造孽钱啊。
啥意思？
就是我写的画的这个青山，这些我所我的所见所闻换的钱。
我用的心安理得。
因为这是我的手艺换的钱，因为他前两句是啥呢？
不练金丹。
不做禅。
不为商故不耕田。
就是我没有去做那些事情，对吧？我没有炼丹修禅，我没有信道或者修佛。
我也没有做买卖。
我也没有耕田。
我。
是个手艺人。
当然耕田有点局限性啊，因为那个年代的人。
有点歧视。
耕田。
但其实耕田也是手艺人。
没有道理歧视他们，但是唐伯虎受那个时代的局限，这个我们就不去多讨论了。
啥意思呢？就是我们安心做一个手艺人。
心安理得，怡然自得，挺好的。好吧，所以同学们不要去担心你能不能学会编剧，也不要去考虑太多编剧能不能走到什么程什么样的程度，能有多牛逼，能不能花团锦簇。你想那些想的太多了。
不要去想这些东西，安心做一个手艺人，对吧？一个著名的木匠。
他的作品千家万户都在用。
他就很开心呀。
对吧没有必要画长锦促走到哪？哎呀，王武讲来了，对吧？这个催去机场堵他，找他签名，没有必要。你的家具大家都在用，你还不开心吗？
别想太多啊。
哎，啰啰嗦太长时间了，咱赶紧上课啊。今天上午时间也有限，下午我还得开会去。
今天讲的知识啊。
叫什么呢？叫。
悬念。
与反转。
今天这一刻啊。
用一个相声的词汇来形容的话，这真叫额乐金德了。
是吧额乐金德的知识，这个词可能字幕组有点困难啊。
额论金德的。
啥意思呢？这个这方面的知识啊，很少有教材，或者很少有老师能给你们讲。
我为什么反复强调？
咱们的课程。
叫实战课程。
不是噱头，不是吹牛逼。
真的是实战课程，为啥啊？
就说编剧这个学问啊，写剧本，做编剧这个这个学科，这个教学它由于不是非常严肃的那种自然科学。
所以呢。
他就往往有很多。
信息有很多信息充斥着在这个领域会对你形成干扰。
但是你去简单分，我教大家一个分类方式，你去简单分关于编剧的知识。
你可以把它分为两类。
编剧的知识啊。
你简单分为两类，一种。
叫事前。
一种叫事后。
别想歪了，好啊。
为什么我说一种叫事前，一种叫事后？
啥意思啊？
我们先说这个事后。
什么叫事后学问？
最典型的啊。
比如说。
我就开始有点亵渎经典了啊。
乔治普尔地的36种故事情景。
对吧。
这个很多。
很多这个这个个这个科班的同学可能听说过。
36种故事情境。
他当然是在戏剧那个年代提出的啊，他把这个舞台上这个戏剧戏剧创作。
分成36种。
有什么啊？
求告。
援救复仇。
牺牲骨肉相残。
然后壮举。
就是。
36种情境，他认为能涵盖所有的。
故此。
当然有很多人去支持他啊很多人去支持他说啊啊分好说的对。
这种就是事后知示。
为啥呢？
他是比如说他找100部剧，1万部剧，然后就开始。
总结分类，往各个地方安。
硬安也他妈安成36种。
为啥呢？因为最早是另外一个学者提出来说，故事情境有36种，是一个应该是一个意大利的叫卡罗科奇。
说有36种，然后呢，但没说具体是哪36种。然后咱这个这个乔治普尔帝就给他。
具体把36种说出来了，说就是这36种。你看所有的故事都是在扯，谁也逃不出去，对吧？这其实就是一种事后学问。
然后在我们编剧教学中有大量的这种事后学问。
事后学问，我不是说没用啊，同学们我不是在讽刺，我只是说它是一种理论研究。
它是一种理论研究呀。
理六研就是很喜欢搞分类总结的嘛。比如说这个这个最早你说咱这个亚里士多德。
他就说故事分四种，对吧？呃，简单喜剧简单悲剧，复杂喜剧、复杂悲剧这种分类啊，它有可能是事前的。
他先把剧分分成两种，喜剧和悲剧，然后呢再有一种维度的分法，就是简单与复杂，这种还是事前的。
但到后期就开始发展成。比如说。
歌德就开始总结说，故事一共分7种。
然后普尔弟他们就说哎呀，情景一共分36种，对吧？然后这这个罗伯特麦基说电影故事分25种，对吧？然后这个那个那个咱们讲过的救猫咪斯奈德说。
类型片分10种。
这些其后面这些啊其实都是事后事后科学事后总结。
这些都是大师啊这些都是大师，就是被分为经典的大师。你到民间一些野路子教学就开始更无法无天了，对吧？设置悬念的168种方法，对吧？然后这个呃这个喜剧片的42种维度。
就开始。
这种事后科学开始泛滥。
事后科学啊。
我再次强调，社科学不是没有用。
他适用于理论研究家，他们搞出一套理论。而且我在讲斯奈德的那节课程，我也给大家说过，我说你不要按照这种方法去创作，你可以用这种方法去检查。
就你写出来一个故事之后，你用他们的方法去套一套，这属于什么类型。然后呢符不符合他们说的那些要素去修整检查一下。我为什么这么说？
修整检查的不就是事后吗？
你得先写呀，明白吗？同学们。
所以我认为在教学中，在实际的教学中，在实战的教学中，最重要的是事前知识。
我教你们创造一个故事，我教你们创造一个悬念，而不是人家都写好悬念了。然后咱哎呀找1万个悬念来放在这100，咱给这些悬念分分类啊，然后叭叭叭一共分出68个类类别，然后告诉同学们。
牛逼吧。
查理对悬念的分类叫查理六八法，分好类了啊，同学们我牛逼吧。然同学们鼓掌下课有什么用啊？
同学们，你在写的悬念的时候，你难道能够先把68首分类先背一遍吗？在脑子里面背一遍吗？然后再支持你创作吗？
所以这种科学啊。
它属于事后知识。
就是这个意思。
就它是一种归纳总结。
对理论研究是有帮助的，可以推进这个这个行业的技术的发展。但是对于我们实战教学。
他指导意义不大。
所以我在课上，我极力的避免给大家讲事后知识。
导致了有些同学啊可能以为我不懂事后知识，不懂各种分类，各种流派，你知道吗？你们难道就喜欢我甩术语给你们听吗？
告诉你们有168种方法啊，回去背。
对吧那这个个有什么用呢？我修那个优越感有用吗？没有用。所以咱这个课啊，我就给大家讲点娱了金得了。
我们讲点事前的，我们讲讲你怎么创作出来。好吧，就是大家一定要理解这个问题，我们为什么在讲。
这些东西为什么讲这些别人没有讲过的东西？
我如果给大家我如果是浪费时间，给大家冲量的话，我给大家讲一讲乔治科尔蒂的36种情境，妈能讲一个礼拜。
浪费时间，你知道吗？没有意义。
我们讲一下悬念和反转，好吧。
事前的实战。
先说一下旋律。
悬念和反转是两个不同的概念啊。
我们先说一下悬念，悬念是个啥？
我在讲。
要素的时候，在前面讲写故事的时候，我反复说，悬念对于一个故事是很重要的。
对于一个故事是很重要的。
他是你观众把影片看下去的理由和动机呀，对吧？那啥叫悬念？字面理解就可以悬而未觉的念想。
就是观众有一个悬而未觉的念想，一直在那念念念着。
念着一个事儿，悬肉一绝，那自然就勾着他把片儿看完嘛。
所以有一些商业片的。
创作者比较极端的那种，他们认为悬念是一个电影最重要的东西。
是不可或缺。
而且要大悬念套中悬念，中悬念套小悬念对吧？就是悬念套悬念，悬念碟悬念。
层层推进，他们有这种。
观点。
这就是悬念，悬而未觉的念想。
那我们就直接说。
怎么样能够。
搞出。
一个好的悬念。
我们来说一下。
有三个特点。
第一。
叫。
未知性。
未知险。
悬念嘛。
所以第一个特点就是未知性，你不知道会发生什么呀。
你不知道后面会怎么样，你不知道何去何从，你不知道怎么回事，你看不懂了。
这就是悬念的第一个特点，最重要的一个特点叫未知性。
比如说。
恐怖游轮。
啊，恐怖游轮啊。
团人购。
英文叫我这个英语口音好像遭受过某一些同学的嘲笑，所以我以后尽量少说，好吧，反正。
同步游轮是悬疑片，应该是悬疑片史上排名前几的。
大玩这个未知性。
不断的。
出来。
跟你长得一模一样的人，对吧？你的朋友明明刚才死了，又出现一遍，你的朋友他不是你的朋友，他要杀你，你也不知道为什么。
就是未知性。
不断的给你未知的东西。
盗梦空间。
是吧。
英文我就不说了，盗梦空间那个词太吵了，盗梦空间是不是就是未知性啊？
你到最后你也没搞明白他到底是怎么回事啊。
大家都在那猜，在那讨论，到底这是几层梦境，对不对？到底有没有回到现实，就是未知性是悬念的第一个特点。
他就是对未来的。
疑惑。
期待。
恐惧都是来源于未知性。
好吧，这是第一种。
啊第二个特点。
叫可能性。
就是你不能老一直玩未知啊。
对吧那这个这个这个他不是刚才死了吗？他怎么又出来了？
对吧你明明看着他已经死了，然后他现在又出来了，而且拿着一杆枪，他要杀你你的朋友。
你一直玩未知，你把观众搞得太迷茫。
也是不行的这不是一个优秀的悬念，就是一个完整的悬念。你除了让观众未知以外，你给他给他一些可能性。
对吧他如果特别迷茫的时候。
你可以点一点它。
这他有可能是个鬼，或者他有可能是假冒。
或者呢有一些暗示有感让观众感觉你是不是有点精神错乱了？
对吧你这个视角人物是不是有点精神分裂呢？是你想象出来的吧。
就是要给观众足够的可能性，至少俩嘛，可能性你至少得给俩。
AA和B嘛。
这才是一个完整的悬念。就是说你制造了一个未知以后，如何再制造可能呢？就是比如说增加一些新的元素，新的线索，新的指向性的东西，或者增加一些新的人物来不断的给你已经挂在那儿的悬念，增加可能性。
这就是。
一个优秀的悬念的第二个特点。
一个优秀的悬念的第三个特点。
施压迫感。
是压迫感，就是说你制造了一个未知的悬念，而且这个悬念有各种可能性悬在那儿。你确实观众是嘛儿看不懂啊，确实一头雾水。但是观众说哦，那我不看了，对吧？看不懂，那不干了呀，关我屁事，我不想猜了。
那也不可以。
你这个悬念得有压迫感。
得压着他，必须让他猜，不猜，你得死。
人家拿着枪来杀你呀。
明白吧？
就是说。
这个事很重要。
压迫感。
切肤之痛啊。
常见的比如说时间上的压迫感。
生死时速就把那定时炸弹摆在那儿，它滴答滴答呀，它有个倒计时，它时间上对你有压迫，你不可能事不关己或者是空间上的压迫感，恐怖游轮，你跑不掉呀。
就是这种压迫感。
让你对这个悬念。
未知，然后又觉得他有各种可能性，你还这个这个真的对这个悬念感兴趣，真的对这个悬念上心啊，我叫感兴趣，上心呢，你得。
就是给你压迫感，压迫感的这个方法。我刚才说了，要么上时间锁，要么上空间锁，对吧？要么就是对这个未来可期，有一个恐怖的前瞻，有一个不好的预言，预示，就是告诉你后面是有大事要发生，而且是不好的大事。往往啊。
往往是不好的大事，这种制造压迫感。这就是。
一个。
完整的悬念。
一个给劲儿的悬念。
的三个特性从这三个方面下手，这就是悬念的三个特点，一个完整悬念的三个特点，或者叫三个要素。同学们去理解一下，好吧。
这个这个编剧上有一句话呀。
叫。
观众越紧张，编剧越轻松。
啥意思呢？你悬念就是让观众紧张的呀。其实啊你就是让观众紧张的吧，你观众只要紧张起来，编剧反而就轻松了。
比如说啊。
你现在甲和乙在对话。
两个主角在对话。
然后呢，你想要写他们俩。
通过这段对话交代一些事情。
比如说是个一段恋爱。
交代他俩现在的关系的程度、阶段处境。
这场戏本来是。
有点无聊，坐在那讲嘛。
然后呢。
观众可能就不太爱看，这时候你编剧不就紧张了吗？你就很紧张呀，哎呀，我怎么样能把这个台词写的如何的精妙，这两个人之间如何交代他们俩的爱情，现在有什么样的问题，到什么样的程度，什么样的阶段，就是你编剧就很紧张。
但是你换个思路。
他们俩在饭店聊天，假设这个饭店有人安了一个定时炸弹。
这个定时炸弹呢就在他俩坐的这个桌子下面，然后观众看到了这个定时炸弹，然后在倒计时，还有5分钟就要爆炸。
还有5分钟就要爆炸，在倒计时。但是这两个演员呢正好坐在这张桌子。
这两个主角，然后就开始谈论自己的感情。这时候紧张的就是观众了。
观众的一想着你俩赶紧逃啊，别吵了，或者真的吵起来也行，吵翻了也好，你们俩就可以对吧？离开这个饭店就不吃饭了嘛，观众就开始紧张了，编剧就轻松了。你这时候写他俩的台词的时候就游刃有余了。
就是这个意思，就是让你的观众紧张起来，这就是。
悬念的作用。
观众越紧张，编剧越轻松，有这么个老话啊。
那么这是全面的。
我们说叫特点或者叫要素。
那设置悬念的方法是什么呢？
咱也有招，好吧，你们只要好好听课，咱永远有招有办法，而且都是事前的，不是事后的。
你不要去网上看啊，悬念的常见的168种模式，那些没有用，你能背下来吗？
你背完了再去写啊，怎么可能呢？我跟你们说悬念。
就是让观众紧张。
人为什么会紧张呢？
所以我说编剧啊这个学科是门杂学。
人在什么样的情况下紧张着急。
心里不踏实，人在什么样的情况下会这种情绪情绪会强烈呢？
我认为。
今天讲的都是我认为好吗？我认为。
在于。
熄火。
在于失控啊。
什么叫失控？怎么样用利用失控来制造悬念？
第一种。
最简单最常用的。
让观众失控。
什么叫失控？失去控制感呀？
失去控制感。
观众相对于谁失去控制感呢？
相对于角色。
他相对于角色失去控制感。比如说。
最简单的办法啊。
倒叙。
或者是省略。
我们的角色。
今天要去。
见自己的女朋友。
今天要去见自己的女朋友，然后呢，路上走着走着，电话响了。
然后呢，他就过去接电话。
打完一通电话之后，电话放下。
在路边五金店。
买了一把斧子。
决定去砍死自己的女朋友。
这是不是悬念？当然是悬念呀，为什么要砍死他能不能砍死他？
但是这个旋钮是怎么造出来的？
就是观众失控了。
观众跟角色的信息不对称了。
你省略了一段。
你跳过了一段，你没让观众知道那通电话的内容。
对吧。
这就是。
省略。
的。
的方式造就观众跟角色的信息不对称，让观众感觉自己失控了，这是省略倒叙也可以。
电影一开场，一个男主角，这个角色拿着斧头。
手上全是血。
对吧然后嘞。
地上躺着一个女人。
头被劈开了，血流了一地，这是开场画面，给你一个结果。
然后开始。
进入正文。
这一男一女是男女朋友，两个人很恩爱的在吃冰淇淋，骑脚踏车，很开心的这也是制造悬念啊。观众会觉得哎。
这一对情侣啊，最后为什么？
男的把女的杀了。
为什么杀了他？
他到底死没死？
或者是是看起来这样吗？是他杀的吗？还是别人杀了，他过去捡起来一把斧头呢？
就产生了各种各样的疑问。
这也是悬念。
也是观众失控了，就这个结果是放在那里，是一是客观存在的，但是就你不知道。
这就叫观众识控第一种方法。
好吧。
第二种方法。
我们说。
决策失候。
角色相对于观众来说时候了。
也是信息不对称。
但是这次是观众知道的太多了。
明白这个意思吗？观众知道的太多了。
哎，刚才那个例子就是嘛？刚才那个例子就是呀，还是这一对情侣在饭店里吵架，桌子底下有个定时炸弹，观众知道他俩不知道。
所以观众着急了。
信息不对称。
信息不对称，角色失控了，观众着急了。
你们快走啊。
对吧？
或者其还有很常见的对吧？这个这个男主角去找一个自己的兄弟去跟自己的兄弟聊天，还在自己兄弟家里很开心，很放松。但是观众着急啊，他已经背叛你了。
他想杀你，你怎么不跑啊，对不对？这不就是。
又是一种失控，又一种悬念了。
就是角色时候。
还有第三种。
也比较常见的。
就是观众和角色。
同时指控。
观众和角色同时失控，这种也很常见。
很常见。
比如盗门空间。
盗梦空间，他们这个穿的层多了，他们也不知道什么是现实，什么是。
是实实梦境了呀，他们自己也迷茫了，观众跟角色一块儿都懵了，都看不懂了。
你知道吗？那这其实也算一种信息不对称，是观众与角色跟编剧之间信息不对称。编剧是同时把观众和角色都耍了。
就让他俩站在一块发懵，我槽到底是谁杀的这个人到底是谁杀的？
观众和角色都不知道。
同时迷茫。
同时在猜。
同时在探究，同时在着急，只有创作者知道。
所以你看这是悬念的三种特点，这是设置悬念的。
三种方法。
你要我让？
角色知情观众不知情，要么让。
观众知情，角色不知情，你要最后或者是让观众和角色同时不知情，同时迷茫。然后。
在设置悬念的时候。
我们说比较。
商业的片子啊比较紧张的那种片子，它往往是大中小。
大悬念。
贯穿时钟的。
中悬念呢15分钟一个，小悬念5分钟一个。
对吧。
比如说。
这种片子这么套法就比较紧张了。
对吧然后比如说大悬念这个这个。
最后到底谁杀的他能不能杀杀成怎么杀的对吧？然后忠贤念是，今天我去杀他。
路上。
那么车一头栽到河里了。
车载到河里了。
车门打不开，水咕嘟咕嘟往里灌。
我可能要死在路上，这又又是一个悬念中悬念。然后小悬念呢哎这时候从旁边过来一个人，过来一个老头，你去老头拿石头给我把车窗砸开，我不就出来了吗？就看这个老头能不能救我。
对吧结果这老头看了看不救是吧？小悬念就是你永远可以套，永远可以制造这些这些悬念，这就是悬念，好吧。
然后与悬念。
很接近的一个概念。
反转这个很多同学就在问啊，大家好像对这个反转很感兴趣，觉得啊一定要有反转戏一定要有反转。经常聊这个词儿，但你知道什么叫反转吗？对吧？很多同学不没有完全了解反转是什么，也不知道反转怎么用。
今天我们借着讲悬念，我们一并把这个概念普及了。
啥叫反转？
字面理解就可以，很简单啊，就是跟你的预期不一样嘛。
跟观众的预期不一样。
这不就是反转吗？所以反转又叫意外嘛。
又叫意外，就是出乎意料之外，跟你预期不一样，就叫反舟。
反转是喜剧当中一个常用的形式，但是不局限于喜剧啊，我只是说喜剧用的比较多，因为在一种喜剧的理念里面。
他们认为这个这个喜剧的元素和段子就在于不断的制造预期，打破预期。啥叫制造预期，打破预期，那不就是反转吗？跟你想的不一样吗？制造了一个预期，然后又打破这个预期嘛？那不就是反转吗？
这就叫反转。所以呢。
制造这个反转。
有没有方法？
有方法，我们这这里就来给大家讲一下，很多同学以为反反转就是开脑洞。
我们经常称为那些反转句，说叫脑洞大开啊，我觉得哦哇那就有脑洞的编剧才能写出反转啊。
哎呀，同学们呐任何一种技能都是可以训练的。
脑洞不是先天的，不要又看啊他怎么吃都不胖，他是天生的，我不干了，不要老埋怨先天的东西，脑洞不是个天赋。
你能训练出来好吧。
制造反转两种方法。
两种方法。第一。
第一。
误导。
很常见。
你想要制造预期，打破预期，跟观众想的不一样。那第一种方法就是误导嘛。
就是误导呀。
你刻意营造这个人做事情特别不讲理，不讲情面，像个坏人一样的。
对吧最后发现他是个好人。
他这么做，其实一直是在保护你。
你这就是在故意误导观众呀。
这必须是是为反转创造了条件吗？
那就是误导。
还有一种方法就是这些年来更做的在影视剧当中啊，我更推荐用第二种方法。
第二种方法。
显得高级那么一点吧。
因为你误导观众，你毕竟有点你故意的，你知道吗？
第二种方法是。
故意隐藏或者克扣。
叫苛扣或隐藏一个能影响。
人物属性、事件走向的重要信息。
就是藏一个信息。
就我不刻意去误导你，但我隐藏一个足以影响人物属性。
事件走向的一个信息。
这也。
是反转，而且往往更柔和。
举个例子。
我们说公交车上。
有个老太太。
每天呢。
也不上班，也不买菜。
但是呢。
就投币2块钱。
在这个公交车上。
站着一个座。
一做一整天。
吹着空调坐着一个座，一坐一整天，他也不是去买菜，也不是去上班。
但这辆公交车。
是一个很繁忙的线路。有很多年轻人啊在为生活打拼，要上班。
对吧？
现在不都讲究错峰出行嘛？年轻人上班的是个时间，老年人，对吧？
那，这样吧，他连2块钱都没投，他用老年卡，70岁以上老年卡就不用。
不用买票了。
就大家都在为了生活打拼去上班，每天这个公交车很挤，但是永远有一个老太太早上一班车就坐就坐上来。
站着一个座。
然后他妈做一整天，这几天老有这么个老太太来。
然后公交司机就。
公交司机和一些经常坐这一趟车的年轻人。
就跟这个老太太发生了争吵。
对吧说老太太，您别省这个电钱了，或者您到商场里去吹空调嘛，为什么老爱坐车呢？
啊，坐在这个公交车上，年轻人都要上班呢，很累的，对不对？
你。
让个地儿嘛，你别在这个车上呆着了，你让个地儿吧。
那么这个老太太就跟他们争吵呀，说我他妈有资格坐这个车，对不对？你们是凭什么让我，而且我年纪这么大，我凭什么给你们让？
然后就发生了争吵。
让大家觉得这个老太太很不讲理。
就是那种坏人变老了，你明白我意思吗？蹭公调蹭公交，蹭公共系统，对吧？仗着自己有老年卡。
这么去讲这个故事，然后反转怎么反呢？
到最后。
发现这个老太太为什么一定要坐这个公交车？我一定要坐一整天，一定要占着这个座儿呢？
是因为他老伴儿。
死了很多年了。
他老伴生钱。
是跟公交公司的播音员。
这辆公交车上的。
到站播报是他老伴的录音。
老头老太太生活了一辈子呢。
因为也没有接触过科技时代。
两个人能留下的念象很少，没有影像，没有声音。
这辆公交车马上就要改线路。
系统升级以后。
就不会再用它。
老外的声音了。
他想抓住最后这几天的机会。
听听他。
老伴儿。
的声音。
他老伴儿。
说。
中山公园到了。
请下车的乘客带好随身物品，先下后上，有序乘车。
就是这么不断的在重复这句话。
他在不断的听。
这个信息。
就是我们隐藏的。
没有让观众知道。
就造就了一个。
反转。
当然我们可以再反转。
年轻人或者这个司机知道了这个情况以后，对吧？
帮。
老太太。
把这个声音录下来。
或者把这个声音原版的文件导出来。
给老太太永远的珍藏，因为老太太不会拿这个老年机，对吧？
这就是反转。
隐藏一个信息。
隐藏一个重要的信息。
好吧。
就是简单举个例子啊，为什么把反转和悬念放在一起讲呢？因为有些同学啊。
老认为这两个是一个东西。
那我们来看一下这两个东西最大的区别是什么？
反转最大的区跟悬念最大的区别是反转是偷偷进行的。
观众没有迷茫，没有疑惑，没有着急。你是冷不丁的给观众来了一下。
悬念呢你是故意制造观众的紧张，故意制造失控局面、信息不对称的局面。
我们说反转也有信息不对称，对吧？你向观众隐藏了一个克扣了一个重要信息，也有信息不对称，但是是偷偷的，你明白吗？
这件事情是偷偷做的，你偷偷隐藏了一个重要信息。
导致观众不知情，导致最后出了一个反转。
所以反转跟悬念是有区别的。
是有区别的。
然后从反转来讲，我还是那句话，大家不要觉得反转。
是多么具有创造性的东西，是多么需要的脑洞。
并不是。
你从这个方法看，反转它根本不是个加法。
它是个减法，对吧？你先写一段戏，然后想办法克扣一个重要的信息，足以影响人物性质，影响事件属性，事件走向的一个重要信息。做一个减法就形成了一个反转，它不是减法，没有那么难。
我们说反转剧中。
在历史上也有名号的，我年轻的时候看过一个剧，一个电影叫盲侠做头饰。
日本电影叫盲侠做头饰。
讲的一个盲侠嘛，眼睛是瞎的，他眼睛瞎的一个武士，就靠听声音。
然后日本那种武士明白吗？拿一个刀跟别人决斗，靠听声音。
来判断别人的位置，然后别人出刀没有别人走到哪了，然后跟别人干仗特别的厉害，特别的猛啊，对吧？虽然瞎的，但是真的刀法是很厉害，无敌。然后呢，他的行动线是去比如说是去报仇，记不清了啊，20多年以前看的找他这个最大的对手，然后这个最大对手知也知道他要来找自己决斗，也在想对策呀。
对吧这个盲侠他这个太猛了，这个这个刀法出神入化。
但是呢他就发现那他既然是听声变位。
我应该干扰他的听觉。
就是他来找我决斗我的天哪。
他不是得听这个。
场地的声音啊，你走到哪了，像跟狗一样，能听到哪边有声音吗？他就把这个场地四周搞得都有声音，这沙子都在响，然后还选了一天风特别大的一天，就说声音啊、气味啊你都无从判断。
就是这么精心布局，想要破掉盲霞。
的。
这个这个这个这个技能，然后这一天来来决斗。
主角和大反派最后这场决斗。
令我印象非常深刻那场戏的反转。
就是两人决斗以后，那个场地确实按照这个反派的设定。
对盲侠十分不利呀十分不利。然后决斗开始，盲侠歘一刀。
放开死了。
就这么简单。
然后故事出出现了最后的反转，往想啪睁开眼。
我根本就不瞎装了这么长时间，就为了宰了它，就他一直是装瞎，明白我这个意思吧？
这就是一个反转。
因为这个反转。
是也是有购无厘头，明白我意思吧？也是有购无厘头。
就是这么玩的。
所以他就是要么是误导你，他这个就是严重的误导你。然后呢又隐藏了一个信息，就是他根本不瞎，对吧？
所以说这个反转跟悬念是不一样。
但是虽然不一样，我为什么要把悬念跟反转同时放在一课里面跟同学们讲呢？
因为悬念和反转还是有共性的，它有个什么样的共性呢？我们大家来看一下。
什么样的共性？
我们不能讲到悬悬念和反转的时候，就讲悬悬念和反转有多好，多牛逼，分多少种方法，多少种类型。我们同学应该如何的认真去学，认真对待我们不搞那种事情，我们始终要保持理性和客观。
悬念和反转这么好，那我们就敞开用吗？
也不是。
全面的反转有个共性。
都是。
涉嫌戏弄观众。
明白吗？
都是你涉嫌在戏弄观众。
你在瞪着观众玩儿。
我为什么说？
到高级的时候，角色跟观众的关系像放风筝样。
我最早的时候说角色跟观众关系是拉小车，对不对？你拉了个小车。
角色在你车上坐着黄包车上，他在你车上坐着，然后你拉着他，哎，咱俩去抢个银行啊，哎，我带你去报个仇，你永远拉着他在经历你的故事，经历你的所见所闻啊。
你俩的距离是。
稳定的。
近的。
同一个角度啊。
但是实际上呢在很多影片的实际操作中。
没有那么简单，没有那么单纯。
就有点开始像放风筝了。
你是那个放风筝的人，观众呢是是那个风筝。
然后你们俩之间有根线连着也不能断呢。
对吧，但是呢。
忽远忽近，若即若离。
你得时刻掌握什么时候把它攥在手里，什么时候把它放飞到天上，什么时候再往回瞪一瞪。
对吧什么时候就拽着他猛跑几步，你得开始控制这个。
这就是。
比较高级比较难的做法。
悬念和反转这里呢他就有这个问题了。
你有点儿。
开始。
涉嫌戏弄观众。
你掌握不好，你就把它惹毛了。就像我说的盲瞎做头事，看到结局的那一刻，我基本上是在掀桌子的。
耍我呀。
他耍我呀。
所以说这是悬念和反转的共性。所以你看啊我在这里为什么专门把这个分开啊，就是误导跟隐藏一个信息啊还是不一样。
还是不一样的。
戏弄的轻。
轻重不同。
所以呢这课最后我想跟大家说什么呢？就是说你想要开始玩转悬念和反转的时候。
你是要有一定的本钱的。
你需要把观众死死攥在手里的时候，你才敢玩的。
就是说你观众你已经。
开户明白了。
胸有成竹了。
或者是你的剧情足够之强，我其他方面足够漂亮。
你才去搞这些事情，才去搞悬念和反转。
因为。
不管怎么说，你也不要去得罪观众，不要去伤害他们。
对吧你可以简单的。
让他们失控一下，戏弄他们一下，误导一下，戏弄一下，或者是让他们失控一下，让他们着急一下。但是你不能失去他们。
对吧不能失去他们。
这节课就讲到这儿，大家去体会一下悬念和反转，好吧。
嗯。